what i wanted to do was take the tropes
of the slasher movie
and use them for gay celebration i am so
grateful to be a part of a movie that
has authentic representation and i think
it'll get people talking
mark
when i was growing up i loved slasher
movies good morning ladies and gentlemen
horror films have a very complicated
relationship with gender and sexual
identity i can't make you straight but
you give us this week we might be able
to help
what i wanted to do was take the tropes
of the slasher movie
and use them for gay celebration voice
cabinet over there girls cabin over
there are you they them pronouns as in
they can't believe they're at this
[ __ ] camp
i've started in slasher films a really
long time ago
what's really brilliant about what john
has done with the script is to
take
a fairly traditional camp slasher movie
who is that and layered on top of that
come in please is the horror of a place
that believes that they can convert
people with pseudo-therapy techniques
it's scary because conversion therapy is
abuse and it is torture that messes with
your entire being do you think your
parents are disappointed in you
sometimes
so what do you do you try to make
yourself
special you become
say
i think we're bringing awareness to
what's actually happening in the world
it's time to play to hopefully bring an
end to the horror that happens at these
camps
i have zero interest in not being gay
there's no judgments in this room when
it came to casting the seven campers it
was very important to me to cast queer
actors sometimes i wish i was invisible
because we have been so underrepresented
in terms of playing ourselves john said
i would like to have young people who
identify with any one of these campers
and root for someone that they see in
themselves i am a gay korean american
woman i am so grateful and honored to be
a part of a movie that has authentic
representation told by authentic
storytellers the best way that we can
assure we are making the best art is to
include as many and as diverse a
population of people possible every
single character represents a different
section of the queer experience i know
what i am what are you it's just a
different environment i haven't seen
before finding my own truth and
celebrating my uniqueness
most important thing to remember is it's
an entertaining movie i didn't set out
to write a lecture if you love horror
movies if you love human drama and
thrillers
this is the movie for you it should be
cozy to even see this concept manifest
on screen i think that john is a genius
today we're gonna be exploring
traditional gender roles we are creating
something completely new here
and i don't have a comparison in my head
we subvert a lot of slasher tropes
so i'm like what's gonna happen
taste
we need to get out of here what are we
supposed to do with trash there's gonna
be a lot of surprises
and i think it'll get people talking
you trust me don't you
[Music]
you